what is film producing begin for you how
do you start off every project I know
you touched briefly on the financing of
course well I think ever every project
comes up in a slightly different way so
it can be that someone walks in with the
money which happened a couple of times
and the project or it can be that I have
an idea or it can be that there's a book
that inspires or that there is someone
who is particularly passionate about a
project and comes to me and you know
wants to be involved and we work on it
jointly so I think all different let's
suppose the money's there good thing you
have a script you you know who you're
going to have is the director what are
the things that you start doing I'm
casting what's your day like first a
sort of on the job so to speak have you
start organizing drones with a checklist
well assuming there's distribution and a
distribution date then I work backward
from there how long do we have to do the
post-production okay how long do we have
them for the shoot how long do we have
for pre-production and I like to get as
much pre-production time as absolutely
as much pre-production time as possible
because it's time and money well spent
because it's not a crew standing around
and a cast standing around while you're
trying to figure out what to do so the
more the more that you can you know be
prepared in pre-production the easier
the shoot in general goes and then you
can address yourself to the inevitable
problems that come up during production
so I would say the first thing that I do
once I had those things in hand the
script the money the director I would
hope that I would have distribution and
know the distribution they and then I
would start with three maybe four vials
cast crew locations and legal
and and begin to put things together
with a list now the first thing I ever
did in film was scout location so i have
also got an idea for a film by visiting
a location and saying to myself i have
to shoot here and then i go looking for
a script rival looking for a book and
then that's how i get it made and i go
back and shoot there one of the places
I've been to in haven't shot is Angkor
Wat in its kind of on my mind a lot so
I'm always looking for a book or a
script that would work well to shoot in
Angkor Wat but other places I've been
and said oh I have to come back is Machu
Picchu in Peru and I shot all up and
down the Nile in Egypt so it excites me
to go to great locations and shoot there
you